alexandra
is in stamford connecticut hi alexandra
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris thank you guys so much
for taking my call sure so i am a junior
in college uh
studying computer science at an ivy
league so i am a hundred fifteen
thousand dollars seven hundred forty
three dollars
in debt so twenty two thousand is
federal loans and the rest
is uh a parent plus loan from my mom so
my parents are immigrants from cameroon
so i was born and raised here
in connecticut and i really
want to work before i get my master's
because i'm pretty sure i'm going to go
to another ivy
and i don't really know how to explain
to them that
because i don't want to be like ashamed
you know everyone keeps saying like oh
once you leave school you're
not going to want to come back but it's
like it's like student loans are normal
for everybody right because it's like at
the end of the day if you have like an
ivy league that means that
you've just made it especially when your
parents have been through so much
in their other country okay
so what do you think i should do what
what what how can we help you what's
your question
yeah so i just want to know like how i
can explain to my family
that i want to work instead of go to
school
[Music]
well your family it sounds like are
not only extremely proud of you
for going to school but also going to an
ivy league school because they're first
generation
immigrants to america correct right
and uh not only they proud of you going
to school they're proud of you going to
that school
and they place a lot of value as you do
based on your
language that you used on ivy league
um uh and so
the point is is they're heavily invested
emotionally in this whole process
so i don't think there are words that
are going to say that are going to
change that
okay in other words i think that you
need to prepare be prepared to
go mom and dad i love you and i
understand why this is so important to
you
but it's important to me to get out into
the workplace and i'll finish up my
masters in an adult program
maybe even not in an ivy uh because
in your world in the i.t world a
master's degree is not necessary for
success
right right a master's degree from ivy
league is sure is crud not necessary for
success in your world
got tons of people who did not graduate
from college making 200 000
a year working for me in technology and
they don't even have a college degree
right and i if they do i sure didn't
look to see if they went to an iv
i looked to see if they could fix a
freaking computer or make it be coded
that's all i wanted them to do right and
i'm the employer yeah
yeah alexandra it's gonna be a matter of
having a reset for them
you know i love the fact that you know
exactly how much student loan debt you
have
and i would love for you to spend some
time to educate them on what's it going
to look like for you to try to chop that
down
how hard are you going to have to work
what's it going to take
and so you give them a good opportunity
to have this learning
experience but i wouldn't be asking i
would be stating
mama hogan told me something i was 16
and i told her i was going to use her
car
and she looked at me and she said bless
your heart and i knew what that meant
i was about to go night night i'm about
to fall down because
she owned the car i couldn't get on the
frying pan and so
what i'm telling you is as to use one of
her phrases
i'm not debating i'm stating and i don't
want you to go in
with your parents to try to debate this
but help them to understand and then
state for them
that they need to what you've raised
them they've raised you to be a smart
independent thinking person and it's
time for you to get to work to chop this
debt down out of your life
and you're going to look at adding
school later on when you can cash flow
it if
it is needed for your success
you do not go get an ivy league master's
degree for no freaking reason
if it is not needed for your career path
because that's a lot
of robotics i want to go into robotics
yeah and you think everybody in robotics
has a master's from an ivy league
wrong answer they don't they are
spatially
gifted they can see things in 3d in
their head
and they've taken that natural gifting
and they move into that field
and they apply technology to it and uh
i've got friends that own robotics
companies
and so it's again it's not you know
uh i i think you're in a particular
world that has
told you a particular narrative and
script
that out here in the real world might
you might find not to be true
so um i'm not saying you can't go back
or that you'd be dumb to go back and get
your masters
at an ivy league in technology i think
that when you get out here and you
figure out that it's not necessary for
you to be successful
in your career field you may choose to
go back or you may not choose to go back
anyway back to your parents
here's what i would tell you you always
start with someone who's been a blessing
to you reminding them that they have
mom and dad i'm so grateful you are
incredible superstars
you have set the table for our family to
win you've gone through such hard times
and gone through such sacrifice to get
us these opportunities
and i don't take that lightly i also
know
that this education and me getting it is
very
important to you to feel like it your
sacrifice was worth it
and i want to tell you it was worth it
and i'm going to prove to you that it
was worth it
i have me i have made the decision
though that i am not going to continue
and get my masters until i get into the
workplace and chop this student loan
down
because it's starting to overwhelm me
yeah and it's starting to become
emotionally a burden to me that's a lot
of money
and i need to get rid of that and then i
will return and get my masters if
i need to in order to win in my career
field and it's just a matter of stating
gratitude
humility and then as hogan said we're
not opening up
you're not asking their opinion you're
telling them
you're not coming back for a masters and
that's
you know that's what you need to do in
this situation and so
there's lots of people you can be kind
to but that don't have a vote
yes that's so true and you could hear
dave even as you were talking to her
in her mind they've ingrained in her she
needs that masters
well she believes and she believes it
and so hearing that and
hopefully her cracking the door and
realizing that hey we're only telling
you what we know
out here in the real world and you've
got a great opportunity as you move
forward young lady
keep your head up yeah there's a lot of
stuff you're going to be able to do
you're obviously very smart
and you're obviously intellectually
bright and you're obviously
uh you know again i i'll just tell you
the
the the statistics on families like
yours are very very good
on your probability of success matter of
fact folks if you didn't know this
um we're gonna do a millionaire theme
hour later today chris and i will
and if you immigrate to this country
legally from another country
you are four times more likely to become
a millionaire than one of us that was
born here
whoa because the statue of liberty means
something yeah
freedom the free enterprise system the
freedom to choose to save sacrifice and
invest
means something different than
one of us that grew up in suburban
playing atari yeah
watching mayberry reruns and so
it's just a different thing it is a
different mindset everybody can do it
but you're in a good situation there
young lady